gegenwärtig findet die
Europameisterschaft im Fußball für
Frauen in England statt und die deutsche
Frauenfußball-Nationalmannschaft ist
richtig toll in dieses Turnier gestartet
das hatte man so nicht erwarten dürfen
und auch nicht erwarten zu hoffen gewagt
und jetzt kommen die ersten wie das
immer so ist die das Begleiten mit
Nebengeräuschen und eine Spielerin Lina
magul vom FC Bayern München hat gesagt
es wäre doch schön wenn Frauen im
Fußball genauso viel Geld verdienen
würden wie bei Männern das ist natürlich
aufgenommen worden der Bulle war es
eingestiegen es wurde heftig diskutiert
an den Stammtischen man hat dabei
vergessen dass sie gemeint hat die
Prämie für diese Europameisterschaft
falls die Mannschaft Europameister
werden würde sollte genauso hoch sein
wie die bei den Herren die ausgelobt war
wenn sie im letzten Jahr Europameister
geworden wäre wie wir alle wissen wann
die deutschen Herren weit davon entfernt
die deutschen Damen könnten das machen
und jetzt wird darüber diskutiert und
ich gebe ehrlich zu ich bin vom Saulus
zum Paulus geworden vor 30 Jahren habe
ich über Frauenfußball nicht allzu toll
gedacht und auch nicht geredet jetzt
habe ich eine Dokumentation gesehen bei
Sky und in der ARD born for this fast
vier Stunden
hautnah seit zwei zweieinhalb Jahren
begleitet ein Team diese deutsche
fußballfrauen-nationalmannschaft und ich
war begeistert ich war von den Frauen
von den Spielerinnen von den Mädels
bisweilen begeistert mit welcher
Ehrlichkeit mit welcher Emotionalität
aber auch Rationalität wie bodenständig
wie offen wie mit vollem Herzen diese
Frauenfußball spielen und zwar für
Deutschland auch darauf hinweisen und
seitdem bin ich richtiger Fan und
unterstütze das also meine Idee ist die
Frauen würden 60 1000 Euro bekommen die
Männer hätten 400.000 bekommen
legen wir das zusammen 460 legen noch
ein paar Euro drauf 500.000 und teilt
die durch 2 wenn ein Fußballspieler der
Herr Nationalmannschaft da verdient
keiner unter fünf Millionen einige über
10 und manche sogar 20 Millionen wenn
der 200.000 Euro auf seinem kontoeingang
nicht feststellt merkt er das gar nicht
für die Mädels wäre das ein
Quantensprung ist wir Weihnachten und
Ostern zusammen und vor allem sie hätten
es verdient letzter Satz in der
Bundesliga ist das was anderes da kann
nur ausgegeben werden was eingenommen
wird und das sind Tarifgespräche und in
die will sich jetzt plötzlich der
Bundeskanzler einmischen das darf er gar
nicht er darf sich in keine
Tarifgespräche einmischen außer dass der
öffentliche Dienst und der Staat ist der
Arbeitgeber das macht er jetzt obwohl er
viele andere Dinge zu lösen hätte
darüber haben wir in der Sendung auch
schon gesprochen vielleicht reden wir
auch noch weiter drüber also Olaf Scholz
kümmern sie sich um das wofür sie
gewählt worden sind und lieber DFB
die Mädels das Geld in die Hand und sie
werden euch große Freude machen und im
nächsten Jahr ist Frauenfußball
Weltmeisterschaft das wird die beflügeln
auf geht's herr Hartmann
ich würde die vorgeschlagen hat toller
Vorschlag nächstes Thema
finden Sie denn generell dass Herr
Scholz kein guten Job macht oder jetzt
nur bei der einen Sache ja ich finde
generell ich habe einmal einmal also die
zeitenwände Rede gehalten hat im
Bundestag da saß ich zu Hause auf meinem
Fernsehsessel und habe mir gedacht das
glaube ich jetzt nicht was da passiert
ist
das hätte ein ein CDU-Kanzler nicht
besser formulieren können nicht anders
formulieren können Friedrich Merz war ja
auch ein csu-kanzler hätte ich jetzt nur
mal so getippt ja eine gewisse Zeit lang
ja hat sie auch ein bisschen verändert
aber das ist eine andere Geschichte
Friedrich Merz konnte ja gar nicht
anders als applaudieren bei dieser Rede
da hat sich nun aus diesem großen Feuer
ist dann ein bisschen Klemmen geworden
und jetzt ist es vorbei weil er im
Prinzip aus meiner Sicht die ganze
Führung aus der Hand gibt wenn wir über
die Bundesregierung reden reden wir über
Robert Habeck und
die bestimmt das Geschehen die bestimmt
die Schlagzeilen Olaf Scholz
drängt sich immer nach vorne
aber Olaf Scholz hat entweder die ganze
Hauptstadt Presse lese ich jeden Tag
dazu kann man nicht antworten wenn man
gar nicht antwortet jeder hat es mit
ihren Fragen versucht er sind wieder
zynisch schnippisch redet viel und sagt
dabei nichts aber er ist er ist völlig
in Hesse sagt man neben der Cup ja und
das ist nicht die Führung die ich von
einem Bundeskanzler erwartet die Merkel
waren nie da der Scholz auch nicht
ja welche Regierung haben wir eigentlich
na die katastropheten sind in den Medien
präsent ja also alle katastropheten
[Gelächter]
aber vorher
bei den letzten Umfragen auf 20%
abgestürzt wie können Sie erklären
gut aber sie ist runtergegangen ja
am Anfang der ukraine-krise Krieges muss
man also ich sagen die Rede an dem
Sonntag auch so gut gefunden ich dachte
jetzt hat das gemacht ich habe dann ab
und zu wurde mal mit der Kamera in in
den Plenarsaal geschwenkt geguckt was in
den Reihen der Grünen der SPD und der
Linken los weil die Linke zwar nicht mit
aber da war auch viel los und da war
viel Tumult der hat offensichtlich nicht
vieles vorher im Detail mit jedem
einzelnen Abgeordneten abgesprochen ich
sag das mal freundlich und da war dann
da ging dann schon los die ganzen
Aktionen im Kopf wie kann man das alles
wieder zurückholen weil sowas muss er
doch nicht haben ne
ich fand ganz gut ich erinnere mich an
Schröder als er damals diese ganzen
Sachen mit Hartz IV diese ganze Agenda
2010 auf dem Plan brachte das war auch
ein Strategiewechsel sozusagen hat auch
was gebracht fürs Land auch wenn so
viele einzelne Menschen eine Belastung
war und schwer war
aber ich habe auch gleich gedacht das
verliert sich wie Wasser im Sand ne das
wird einfach gehen das war ja wirklich
Zeitenwende ich habe einen guten Spätzle
der ist sozusagen 50 Jahren und der hat
gesagt du musst dir das mal vorstellen
der hat mit einer Rede 150 Jahre SPD
Geschichte auf den Kopf gerichtet hat er
gemacht und davon ist leider
die Koalition ist vielleicht zur
falschen Zeit dran gekommen also das hat
ja 89 auch schon mal gegeben die These
dass die eigentlich vier Jahre zu spät
dran kam weil Kohle eine Verlängerung
gekriegt hatte und die ganzen ganzen
Strukturreformen die wir noch auf den
Servietten gekriegt hatte deswegen WGs
jedermann vorher bleiben einmal bei der
personale Olaf Scholz als Kanzler
Philipp welche Note würdest du denn Olaf
Scholz als Kanzler geben jetzt
unabhängig vom Frauenfußball
aber du darfst auch noch was zum
Frauenfußball sagen das hat er hat mir
extra mitgebracht natürlich darfst du
dazu auch was sagen
ich
würde Olaf Scholz vielleicht irgendwas
zwischen einer 3 und einer 4 geben aber
ich bin froh dass er Kanzler ist und
nicht Armin Laschet weil Armin Laschet
ein Pro russischer Kanzler geworden wäre
meiner Meinung nach seine Position sind
mindestens genauso Russland freundlich
wie die von Olaf Scholz und dann hätten
wir ein Pro russischen Kanzler Laschet
und eine pro russische SPD in der
Opposition und das wäre wirklich der
Super-GAU gewesen jetzt haben wir
immerhin die Union die aus der
Opposition und ohne Lasche treiben die
drei noch für Olaf Scholz und wärst du
sonst härter in der Bewertung es ist
noch zu frisch um mit wirklich sehr
guten oder sehr schlechten Noten
einzusteigen Herr Knop welche Note
würden Sie denn verleihen ein Herr
Scholz als Kanzler also ich sehe es
wieder aus fußballsicht das ist ja auch
das eigentliche Thema von Waldemar
Hartmann ich denke mir wenn das jetzt so
ich überlege jetzt gerade Meisterschaft
Spiel in der Kreisliga A und dann läuft
der kleine da vorne also nichts gegen
den kleinen aber mit dieser
Kapitänsbinde und das ist jetzt der der
unter ich bin mir ich wäre vielleicht er
fühlt er sich auch deswegen Berufen über
Fußball zu reden weil er denkt ich bin
genauso groß wie viele blam keine Ahnung
aber
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin da
auch noch nicht so wirklich also ich bin
da nicht so so für mich ist das ich habe
es ja gesagt also für mich sind die da
auch ob es Haarwerk ist oder oder
Gesicht nein nein nicht schüchtern aber
ich würde das jetzt auch nicht an einer
Person machen dass die eine Person
sondern für mich ist das ja ist das ja
eine Mannschaft die da antritt und ich
habe ja schon vorhin schon gesagt was
ich bis jetzt von der Leistung dieser
Mannschaft und auch durchaus von dem was
kurz davor gewesen ist gehalten habe
also ich bin da nicht überzeugt auf
jeden Fall eine Note weiß ich jetzt
nicht ob ich die vergeben würde ich will
zum Beispiel sagt ja der eine ist jetzt
zwar nicht doll aber der andere wäre
noch schlechter gewesen das ist ja
eigentlich sollten wir wenn wenn man in
so ein Spiel geht in der Kreisliga dann
sollte man auch eine geile Truppe
ausfällt schicken und nicht der eine
humpelt aber der andere hat am Knie der
dritte der ist auf einem Auge kann er
nicht gucken aber ist noch der beste man
wählst du maximal 17 da akzeptiere das
Herr Knopf aber nur weil ich so gespannt
bin schon seit heute morgen
[Gelächter]
alles falsch mache ist ein sehr gut gut
befriedigend ausreichend mangelhaft und
Ungenügen die beiden die beiden letzten
kenne ich aus meiner eigenen Zeugnissen
okay und wenn ich seine Arbeit als
mangelhaft bezeichne dann muss ich ihm
eine fünf geben das heißt nämlich
übersetzt 'ne fünf gut mangelhaft ich
finde er fährt mit angezogener
Handbremse hat mal kurz lassen
mal kurz gucken lassen das auch was
anderes ginge und hat er sich in seine
fußtruppe umgeguckt Alter wie ein König
abreiten müssen mit dem Schwert an die
Schulter heute ist ein guter Tag zum
Sterben stattdessen saß nicht alle da
und haben ihre zehennägelegt lackiert
ich glaube das wird so nichts mit der
tropical das nicht bringen stimmt ja und
jetzt bin ich sehr gespannt was mit der
Schneeflocken Gesellschaft das war schon
Nationalmannschaft
das Spiel gegen die Spanier gesehen und
da muss ich sagen die Spanierin haben
wir wirklich super gefallen unsere
natürlich top verteidigt vorne zwei
Hütten gemacht aber man muss sagen die
können mittlerweile wirklich auf Fußball
spielen die Mädels das kommt ja noch
dazu und das ist also da hast du schon
[Gelächter]
DFB wenn Sie das jetzt hören gehen sie
gerade an die Kasse und sagen
[Gelächter]